so today we're making something a little
different from born for the legends a
few years ago I made a pretty deep study
of the games of Marcel Duchamp who is
way more females not in the chess world
but in what world that's right in the
art world so there is a lot of interest
in Marcel Duchamp across the street and
the reason that there's so many
interconnections between chess and art
is partly because Marcel Duchamp was
such an aficionado of the game of chess
not only was he one of the most
influential artists ever but he also
played chess at the master level and
even gave up his art career for a time
so that he could focus only on chess
part of the reason that I think he's
such an impressive artist is that it was
really important in his career that he
didn't like want to copy himself and
just like do the same thing over and
over and just get paid you know like
make a painting very similar to one that
he did before so that he could keep
making a lot of money which is of course
very smart but you rejected that because
he didn't think that was like the
artistic thing today huh and so that's
one of the reasons he got into chess
because in chess you never play the same
game right well very very rarely in my
last class I was teaching about the
scholars made and how to prevent it to
people just starting out and of course
that's the exception that many
youngsters play the scholars made five
or six times until they get so strong
that their opponents start start
stopping at right those scholars made
for you right Winston that's right no
scholars made for you so this is one of
Marcel Duchamp's games he's playing with
white in this position and the question
is what would you do for white and try
to calculate how the game might conclude
so marcel duchamp born in france spent a
lot of time in the United States moved
here at some point living in New York so
let's take a little more time see if
everybody has an idea so you're looking
at work these six Bishop d6 Queen takes
c6 checked you're looking at work f7 and
then pawn takes d6 right so my question
is you stop analyzing at that point or
do you think it's like necessary to
calculate the checkmate or do you feel
like you did enough okay excellent
that's a good response I mean I think
like it depends on how much time you
have on your clock right but in this
position there are certain sacrifices
where you really need to be sure you
calculate to something definitive like a
checkmate for instance when you
sacrifice a whole queen or when you
sacrifice a rook for no other material
if you're not checkmate in your opponent
you're gonna be in big trouble right
where it is in this case you really
don't have to talk calculate the
checkmate and the reason is that after
work to do sex this excellent move right
very nice move you really want to get to
work to these six and at first it looks
like you can't because this bishop is
guarding the square but after a Bishop
takes d6 we now have a nice in-between
move instead of just taking this we
instead interpolate what Winston exactly
it's really important to insert this
move that's also called an in-between
move plus that's right
Queeny six plus what is it called
besides an intermediate move does
anybody know the fancy German word for
at ten oh that's the Italian word for it
Intermezzo
intermediate move yeah swishing Zoo is
apparently the best way to call it but
you know that if a move has so many
different names it must be really good
right so
queen zz6 checked in terminal and now if
the work blocks in f7 which is what
happened in the game after pawn takes d6
I agree that white does not have to
calculate till checkmate here because
our compensation is so overwhelming
we're not really down material right I
mean let's count this up guys what are
we down material no we're actually even
and of course even based on the
materialistic quantification of these
pieces but in reality we're a lot more
than even right I mean this Bishop is an
absolute monster now with all these
squares so when we took this one we took
here not only do we capture that Bishop
but we made this Bishop the best piece
on the board right furthermore this pawn
is also not not a mere pawn but a very
important passed pawn so white is
crushing here now after Queen d7 how
many people trade Queens raise your hand
if you like the trade Queens there okay
nobody wants to trade Queens so sad no
no it's not sad at all and it's very
good but what would you play
Wilson Queeny five that's right now oh
that's great you're related and you play
the same move here
well Queen to e5 is a really important
move I mean it seems really obvious now
when I'm teaching you in in a class but
as I talked about in almost every class
a lot of us and one of the frequent
grandmasters and residents Ben Feingold
I know it's one of his typical topics as
well almost all chess players have this
problem of trade itis they trade too
much of course this would be an extreme
example of it Queen takes e7 would be
massively terrible
even if White's doing pretty well here
it's not I mean if we could play e5 or
something it might be a little different
even that wouldn't be nearly good enough
but after Bishop e5 you can argue about
whites massive compensation and even say
like hey why it's gonna be totally
winning after this but it's still not
nearly as good as keeping Queens on the
board and not even have to calculate any
of that right so that would be an
egregious example of trade IDs but there
are many more minor examples that you
should watch out for in your own game
instead marcel duchamp did play Queen to
e5 and the game was over soon thereafter
I think actually this position was just
resigns but this is the best thing for
black to do now of course this is a
devastating threat of checkmate in wine
so black has to move the rock and
there's not a lot of good squares to do
it because when you move the rook we get
to go Queen a check and then we take how
many pawns too many pawns right we're up
for pawns in this position so we're down
what do you call it when we have a work
for a bishop I know a lot of people know
this but what does that call do you know
what that's called Winston when you have
a rook and your opponent has a bishop
what are you up nice right to bonds but
we have a special chess phrase for right
no you don't you don't know it's that's
okay I'm 10 yeah we call it being up in
exchange all right and I like the the in
French they had called the
the exchange quality I like that I don't
think I'm saying that right but I saw it
written in French and I was like that
makes a lot more sense than in English
because they didn't was being up in
exchange when you try to explain that to
somebody who's just learning the roles
or like isn't every exchange the next
time but no the exchange specifically
means work for a bishop or and I hate
and the reason we don't use Winston's to
pawns is that frankly usually it's a
little less than two pawns usually a
bishop and two pawns are a bit better
than a rock so the exchange is like
sacrificing somewhere between one and a
half and two pawns usually that's why it
needs its own specific name yeah well
the problem is you're also down pawns
right yeah I mean well that's also just
like yeah over hey what are you gonna
promote to good good answer so are you
trying to promote to a knight no that's
too much fun yeah I suppose have that
much fun when you play just unless your
opponent's been really really annoying
and even then even then I wouldn't do it
so that was a really nice victory a nice
clean victory by Marcel Duchamp which
goes to show I mean and also remember
this is in 1928 so it might seem really
obvious to us now but remember that a
lot of these patterns that's right in
1928 right there because it's recorded
with the game data so a long time ago
and 1928 a lot of these patterns weren't
as well known so you didn't like see a
bunch of books with very similar
sacrifices so it required even more kind
of creativity and imagination to find
moves like work to desex right in
addition to in between move this has
also got another name this type of
tactic anybody know yeah
not really intermediate step this is a
kind of con yeah not really deflection
it's got a special name yeah clearance
yes clearance and also blocking blocking
when you like when you interfere between
two things and block the defense so it's
got it like most tactics in chess
it's a combination of different themes
right so here's another one another
Duchamp game this one he did not win but
that's okay
here he is winning though he had a good
move in this position so he is white in
this position and as you can see it's a
kind of crazy material imbalance White's
got a queen for a rook a night in a
bishop hmm yeah so that's a really
bizarre material imbalance but what do
you notice
so like in points what's worth more the
work night in the bishop or the queen
right but that's not the full story here
right because we didn't go count the
pawns yet right white does have an extra
pawn and there's something else to this
what else is going on in this position
that makes it much less clear than that
Wilson yeah yeah that bishop here is not
got a lot of squares to go to okay so
what would you do if you were white to
try to make this super clean means like
you're doing well so let's stop there
counter play let's make so that they
can't attack us too easily
yeah Kenneth to that the problem here is
that were really worried about some kind
of sacrifice one of the important things
in chess the stronger you get which the
great chess writer over at ski talks
about a lot is prophylaxis so you want
to think about what your opponent is
gonna do and in you know prophylaxis is
like basically it's a fancy word for
defense but defense even in positions
where it doesn't seem like you should be
defending it's looking for your
opponent's ideas and threats and even
though it's white you might be pretty
excited about your position in your
opponent's king is weak you're gonna
take on each one the bottom line is
black still has ideas of us all so let's
make sure to keep our eyes open for them
okay we're key for is a great move
because it is it actually does stop his
ideas in the game actually marcel
duchamp did not make that move he played
a work h4 kind of more going for that
aggressive attack because he didn't he
was thinking my positions awesome I'm
gonna win this game so why not just try
to take this pawn off and accentuate
this weak King all that makes sense but
we got to give her opponent some credit
too right we always assume that our
opponents gonna play the best moves
that's an important thing in chess
because if you're wrong and your
opponent plays bad moves you're gonna
win anyway so you might as well assume
that they're gonna play well so after
work th for what extra resources black
cap now that makes the position very
complicated okay exactly Bishop except
three is what happened we're gonna look
at that in a second and now the game
kind of blows up because black manages
after Bishop f3 point up three work
takes d3 now everything's a mess right
threes in take and if they take on f3
our rooks in take this work is coming
this King is starting to get weak so
some of these positions super messy
right whereas after Wilson's move rookie
4 super solid excellent move now after
Bishop takes f3 instead of allowing this
mess what else can what you do here
now wait has another choice what's up
exactly now we just capture the night we
don't deal with any of this funny
business and after we captured of the
night now the position is more simple
now we just have a queen for a what we
just have a queen for a working a bishop
and look who's King is still super weak
all right blacks King is still very weak
our King is looking a lot safer because
the rooks aren't piling in like they
were and like they do in the game so
very good move and that's that's about
looking for your opponent's threats even
when they haven't been playing well even
if your opponent seems like they're
they're going down they're not playing
well you still want to be vigilant and
make sure that you're looking for all
their ideas so instead work h4 Bishop
takes out three and now work to dethrone
I was just pointing out that this is now
looking pretty ugly now actually in the
game Marcel Duchamp lost this game he
played the move Queen to e2 and ended up
losing but we're gonna look at a way he
could have played better so if he had
played Queens he won instead this move
is a little stronger because we are just
for basically concrete reasons but we're
really trying to get some counter play
against this King as quickly as possible
before it's too late and now black
played worked the d8 to protect this
rock right because taking this work
still not possible
cuz this work isn't a great so work the
d8 instead creating all sorts of
interesting threats yes white did check
actually and now after King h8 now as
you think as you can see Queen tangs d3
is a move you would certainly look at
but at the end of the variation black
does get to take on h4 so we don't end
up material like we would like to so
instead
rook takes h5 exactly and now we do have
some breaths like we are threatening now
for instance if black were to do
something random here now white would be
able to play what just to try to
simplify the position and win easily
without having to sweat too much yeah
now we could play Queen takes d3 because
there's no mate takes h4 at the end of
the variation I noticed that a
grandmaster joel benjamin recently came
out with a book on simplification and
liquidation and it's a slippery slope
you don't want to go too far with it but
in always look for ways to simplify
because i can lead to trade itis but at
the same time when you're winning it's
really important to think of ways to
just wipe everything off the board so
that you can just be up a walker up a
piece or up in exchange and make the win
easier so black in this position please
the move Knight to g1 check and now
white played King to e1 and black played
back to f3 way to play King EE 291 check
well actually this is a variation so
white is trying to win this game but
black keeps checking us right so let's
try King f2 now now what can black do
we're trying to perpetual check light do
you know what perpetual check is Winston
okay that's right keep on checking
well if we keep on checking our opponent
is that a win or a draw it's a draw
right well you don't need to do it 50
times if it's a perpetual check actually
anybody you see besides uh yeah
so we're kept eight check is the right
way very good that's what you were gonna
say too right Wilson
and now after King takes do you on your
same idea Rick do you one check but now
the king can't come up so even though
we're up a queen it doesn't help the
King has to keep in this box right so
kim ji-won worked you on king h to work
d to check King H won Rick do you want
check so a really cool potential finish
to that game even though ultimately
white should have just been winning the
game with that working for a move that
you suggested right but this would have
been another way to do it now I actually
made a video related to that which I'll
show you an excerpt of right now so this
is who HS which is a combination of
hula-hooping in chess and you'll see
you'll recognize that position coming up
in just a minute so the idea of this is
to be able to exercise and play chess at
the same time and you see that this
position with their work in the king
coming back and forth that's from that
game so exactly the same position this
is a short excerpt of it it's only like
40 seconds long there's a full version
on YouTube where you can really see the
entire endgame that we just looked at
play out so I thought I'd show you that
and an homage to a Marcel Duchamp so one
more Marcel Duchamp game that I want to
show you this one will look at the full
game so we were looking at experts
before and this time we'll look at the
full game I like that in this game he
played my favorite opening
ah now anybody else here played this is
silly n-no what's up with that nobody
plays as a Sonia in this test Club is
this an anti Sicilian Chess Club
what's that because of our because of
our and Yasir yeah take that Barbara's
gonna go beyond yeah the French is a
great opening but the Sicilians really
cool
it's very closed if you like the
position to be closed you like the
French but a lot of youngsters prefer
playing open positions uh why anybody
know why why the French is so popular
for somebody like version of Cobian yes
because of Petrosian and the world
champion who played the French I'm not
saying that's why I Co bein played it
but it is very popular among our medium
players or players of Armenian descent
so definitely a great resource from the
French is a great opening I hated
playing against it Bobby Fischer hated
playing against it a lot of people hate
playing against the French but Sicilians
a really nice opening and what variation
of the Sicilian do you play well we're
talking about is black which is black
how do you develop your pieces here do
you play this is a little bit of a
strange way to develop usually black
plays Knight f6 earlier but suppose
white what would you play in this
position you play knight c6 and then
when they play d4 what do you do okay
and then when they take back what do you
do and then where they play here
okay you should know what you do exactly
because these lines are very very sharp
okay so how do we the next time you work
with your coach I would make sure that
you know exactly what you're doing in
this Sicilian because it sounds like
you're a little shaky on the move order
okay
because there's all sorts of ways to do
it you could play a six and you could
play D six or you could try to
fianchetto your Bishop at some point but
it's the sharpest opening in chess and
you want to be really sure in any case
in this game marcel duchamp played a
line called the dragon yeah dragons are
cool opening so the dragon is
characterized by feom kattiline this
bishop over here on the Kings side yeah
this is kind of more of like an
accelerated dragon although with the
accelerated dragon usually the pawns not
even on d6 yet so this is like a
slightly strange move order where white
at black has an early night c6 now back
in 1924 the Sicilian wasn't as popular
it is now so probably they're just kind
of experimenting a little bit Bishop b5
what do you guys think of this move yay
or nay
yeah your nein you say okay reasonable
yeah I think [ __ ] if t7 is the best
move and furthermore I actually think
that there should be five is not that
good of a move because in the Sicilian
it kind of optically looks decent
because it looks like you're being
aggressive but the reality is that you
don't really want to trade this bishop
off that much you want to keep as many
pieces on the board as possible and also
this Bishop who's gonna go to d7 anyway
so you're just kind of helping me
develop and in fact I might create some
threats against this bishop that will
help me with my attack later on so
Bishop e5 is actually a move that shows
that you maybe don't know what to do
against a Sicilian
I like your idea of putting the bishop
on c4 a lot better or even more so
normally in this position white ends up
hassling in which direction Queen side
so if we're gonna Castle queenside
what's more important to develop this
bishop for this bishop exactly so
normally if you wanted to develop the
Yaak Bishop first but here we actually
want to develop this Bishop first and
maybe then the Queen and Castle so
certainly Bishop c4 is not a bad move
but I would even prefer just to play
Bishop e3 right away and you know just
get get get on Queen side Kathleen ASAP
yes yeah that's true I mean it's risky
but it's also the reason that so many
people don't play the dragon because
it's a very strong line if you are gonna
Castle kingside then you're gonna bend
Bishop c4 or Bishop e2 or both better
than they should be five so either one
of those are okay if your plan is the
Castle kingside
so if it should be five not a great move
but obviously not a disaster yet
so now f3 f3 is a move that looks a lot
prettier when we Castle queenside
because when we Castle kingside it
creates some weaknesses so again in the
opening battle it seems like marcel
duchamp knows what's going on a little
bit better so far right all of his moves
look fine white smooth look a little bit
shaky like this whole idea of Bishop III
Queen d2 is beautiful but we want our
King over here when we do it so that we
can then do use these pawns to crush
black right to open up those lines here
it's kind of mixing up two ideas so
after Queen a5 night be three Queen c7
now white made this decision to take on
c6 what do you think of that why do you
not like that
well I will just simplify that and say
that this position is pre open it's semi
open as they say one pair of pawns have
been traded but it's not on the same
file so there's not that many open lines
but that being said any semi open or
open position you usually want to have a
reason for trading a bishop for a knight
it's not good enough to have no reason
Bishop's are slightly slightly better
than the Knights and let's have a reason
for it why are you taking on c6 don't
just do it because it's possible again
that's trade itis there's another reason
after Bishop takes c6 and when you ought
to think about how you would recapture
in this position and then we'll take a
vote look think about it for a minute
sorry cuz I want everybody to
participate on this one all right let's
have that vote how many people here
would capture with the Queen okay how
many people would capture with the pawn
how many people would capture with the
bishop okay
anybody who captured with the pawn
wouldn't give a reason why okay what
else mm-hmm anybody with bishop want to
give reason yeah
I'm that Diana right there you sitting
here
there's over Twitter but only musics
like blocks with the night
okay that's that's a decent reason Vania
true okay and I agree with that I think
that's a good reason um that's a good
reasoning in the back so you you chose
upon what did you choose
okay great well this is this is great
you guys did a lot of good thinking here
and now this is a wonderful example of
where you need to think with words
because variations are not really
suffice Amin there's not really a lot of
tactics after Bishop takes c6 or pawn
takes c6 and this is what we call
positional chess or strategic chess then
you need experience and understanding in
order to make the right choice the
correct choice is to take with the pond
but um you guys all made a lot of really
good points the reason the pond is the
best is because not because of the B
file not as much because of the B file
because you're you're totally right but
the C file is also good the main thing
here is this D Phi square the D Phi
square having control over that's really
useful because frankly White's position
here is a little blah and one of their
only ideas is to get a Knight to d5 it's
a position you know like and for that to
be good like for instance to try to get
Bishop g5 Bishop f6 and 95 or to just
get 95 in and then you know create
pressure on the e-file because they're
gonna be forced to take that's one of
whites only ideas so when they take on
c6 and we take back like they really
don't have a lot of play um this this
pawn protects a lot of their active play
and meanwhile we still have active play
with rook b8 and a5 type stuff yes
okay I see that you're thinking me the a
plan now is isolated but at the same
time this pawn we still have to pawn
islands right we just moved to one
really big one and I think that the a
plan is going to be used to try to go
like a four and really hammer on his
weak be pond so what you're saying makes
sense but it's just not the overriding
principle in the position right a lot of
times and chest you have contrasting
principles you have to pick one and here
the this is more important so as you'll
see it's kind of a theme that we're
trying to destroy our opponents
counterplay that's usually good because
not only is it just good for obvious
reasons but it's also really extra
annoying to a human opponent right we
don't play against computers we play
against humans and when when you deprive
them of their activity they get very
upset you know they get antsy and make
bad moves so Bishop eight-six is fine
and now marcel duchamp made a bad
position ah yeah actually but something
was very instructed so he did win this
game but here he'd made a bad move he
played the move c5 which can I
contradicts everything we just talked
about yeah but I mean if I didn't say
all that like I like it I feel like see
if I the mistakes that a lot of people
make because it looks aggressive he
wants to maybe a play c4 um hit this
night maybe play work b8 and c4 so if
you don't think about it more deeply and
theythey fight not really possible yet
because if you do it right now it seems
a little early I mean it might be
possible actually just do it right away
but it's a little dicey but whether you
can play now our next move it's it's
just like you're never going to be able
to move your pawn back to c6 right
that's that's why pawn moves are so
important for a strategic chess where
they say the pawns are the soul of chess
so o instead of c5 just rook b8 and
which pandu you want to use to hammer
this night away
and work on this pond yeah we want to
use the a pond not the sea pond do the
eight points not doing anything now
anyway and then suppose just to give you
a sense of how bad this position is for
y8 because it's not that bad but it's
not very pleasant so you wait gets his
King out of the way we play a Phi they
play work d1 I'm gonna play a four to
stop it they they play a four to stop a
four
well I guess a for it's not an immediate
threat because I'm not a c4 but it
probably will become one soon because we
can because we can play Queen eight
seven and a four but suppose they play a
four now what can we do to further the
pressure along this line
yeah yes exactly Bishop e6 move it looks
a little bit bizarre non Sicilian
players because you're putting your
Bishop in front of a pond but you know
what we don't we're going to move this
pawn anyway and then this Bishop hits
this Bishop this Knight here and there's
a lot of pressure on this line and see
how we do this and meanwhile White has
almost zero counter play so that is
that's what we want but instead John
played c5 you know anyway ended up
getting a good position expanding here
and the Queen side and I'm kind of going
through this a little bit more quickly
because I want to make sure to show you
the end of the game as well not just the
beginning so work 83 is a really nice
move just trying to increase the
pressure in the position and stop white
from ever being boto but a free himself
with something like eighty four maybe
Knight b5 someday this move just stops a
lot of whites active ideas
so this is kind of an interesting move
Bishop c8 what do you think the idea is
there so Mitchell Mundi 7 looks like
it's more developed than on CA but what
can I do on CA that I can't do on d7
anyone who lesson tried yeah where do
you think the bishop might be coming to
yeah what do you think
which was yeah exactly after one of the
nights which square would you use yeah
very good [ __ ] basic so between 16
Northstar just putting a lot of pressure
on your opponent's position like this
night isn't take this pawn is kind of
loose and again when you put all that
pressure in your opponent sometimes
they'll top off so Bishop here developed
but doing nothing Bishop here back to
its starting square but do way more so
that sometimes happens in positions
where you have a big edge because you
have more time because your opponent
doesn't have any counter play right no
counter play here for right well as I
say that they make a move it gives a
little bit of counter play again that
move that he played earlier c5 allowing
a little bit of play on that d5 square
right so now just wanna play Bishop to
e6 hoping to just shut down that idea
altogether and now after work d2 work to
be four was played and now it's gonna
get kind of exciting what do you think
some of blacks options are here take a
little take a little thought here maybe
white should have taken on e6 at some
point but I think blacks idea was then
again that pawn on e6 would have stopped
at the counter play on d5 so think about
what you might do is black now so we
were talking earlier about the exchange
in chess and how it's not worth that
much to be up in exchange so we have to
be open to ideas that give up a rock and
being a lot of material in exchange
that's a big hint sorry yeah Wilson rook
takes b3 beautiful move rook on work on
I assume you meant that rock yeah we're
takes b3 very nice move now the idea is
that after pawn takes b3 work takes b3
look at how much material black is
getting back by force right what are
they gonna get after four
since Queens yuan they're also getting
the night back to their right and now in
this position if you count up material
what's going on
what's going on materially wise and this
materially in this position can no
blacks not a play since you got it the
reverse take a minute to count and then
we got some math math whizzes in the
glass black is up two pawns and and down
the exchange right but but but there's a
lot of the good things happening is
position first of all notice his King
safety secondly notice the activity of
his work in his queen thirdly look how
dangerous this pawn is so it seems to me
that black is doing very well in this
position I I think white is in trouble
actually so this would have been kind of
bad yeah you think it's even so you
don't you don't really think black has
an advantage oh yeah
but if you look at the position it looks
like white doesn't have as much play as
black right like something like this and
now black's pawn here just looks very
strong to me right and even this king is
still kind of weak in there so i would
be very happy playing this position as
black but this still white should have
done something like this you know
there's certainly some fight left in
that position
it's just that black is in my opinion
much better and it's much easier to play
for black as well you have a question
okay eight a question yeah unfortunately
for white you kind of panicked in this
position I guess you just thought that
that those lines we were looking at
we're so terrible with a you know Queens
after work takes b3 you could even
untried Queen a1 I think that's even
better because I think this position is
more more playable for white than the
one we just looked at because why how do
we make a decision when we want to trade
Queens
it's very similar to the last position
we looked at except now there are no
Queens on the board and last position
there were Queens so who does it benefit
when Queens are removed I think it's a
little bit more nuanced than that
because sometimes when you're defending
when you're attacking you wanna when
you're ahead you want to trade Queens to
make a position more simple it's really
about who's King is safer here right if
you know if you look at position we were
looking at earlier it was definitely a
blacks King who was a safer right like
Queen c1 work c3 in this position this
King here is actually like almost
impossible to attack whereas this King
is a little bit vulnerable on this
diagonal right and even if it goes to h1
it still could get kind of tight get
kind of back ranked at some point so the
King safety is really issue the safer
your king the more you want to keep
Queens on the board right so that's a
logical way that in this position you
could decide hey I'm in a little bit of
trouble my opponent has plenty of
compensation for the exchange but it's
probably a good idea for me to exchange
Queens here and try to play this
position again black is down in the
exchange and has two pawns for it
instead white panic mode and just took
this here I'm thinking that in this
position after would be 3 c4 of course
that's the idea now we can get some
material back that there would be some
way to save here but in fact we continue
to to get this fork in and the pawn on
d3 is just going to be really powerful
all right so here we have a queen for
two rooks but on top of that this pawn
on d3 is beautiful and we have another
pawn in addition right so very nice
position for black
and the game was over pretty quickly
thereafter as you as you see still
there's these issues with the King
safety right so the knight can't take on
d3 and the rook can take on b3 because
of why
what happens if work takes c3 there's
just a checkmate right Queen e1
checkmate so that forces white to play
h3 and now with the knight coming in and
the pawn beautiful it's uh it's over
right
so these pawns coming into the game and
as you can see the rooks are not working
very well against the Queen right
whether or not a queen is better than
two rooks again has a lot to do with
King safety and the coordination of the
rocks in this position the work is tied
down to the defense of this pond so
they're kind of useless compared to this
very powerful Queen so that was one of
my favorite games by Marcel Duchamp and
I also showed you one of his losses and
another one of his wins I hope you
enjoyed it yeah die if you want to learn
more about do chompin chests you can
check out this book Marcel Duchamp the
art of chess and also there's just a lot
of information about it online so any
other questions you guys have yes I
didn't use about masters trial it's all
relative right because you know of
course today the opening knowledge is a
lot higher but he was very strong